[موسيقى]
هو عباره عن صعوبه في التواصل الاجتماعي
وصعوبه فيه تكوين العلاقات الاجتماعيه
الطفل اللي عنده شمال توحديه هو ما يفهم
بعض العلاقات الاجتماعيه اللي تصير في
نطاق الاسره او في المدرسه في البدايه في
المراحل الاولى من عمر الطفل هو يحس ان
لما تنادين اسمه ما يلتفت صعوبه التواصل
البصري واذا كان يتواصل شوي فيحاول
يعني يمنع التواصل فيما بعد يكون عنده
روتين روتين معين ما يحب يكسر روتين ويكون
عنده بعض الاطفال يكون عندهم حركات متكرره
[موسيقى]
احنا كلمه توحد ما نقولها اليوم لكن نقول
سمات توحديه لان اكتشفنا في اختلاف كبير
بين طفل واخر واحد عنده قدره عاليه وهذا
الطفل ممكن
يتاقلم ويتعلم وان شاء الله نتائج تكون
زينه في المستقبل في بعض الاطفال اللي
شخصناهم عمرهم ثلاث سنوات لما يصير عمره
عشر سنوات تلاقيني اكتسب مهارات كثيره
مهارات اجتماعيه ومهارات علميه والكتابه
والقراءه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طرق المثلى للتعامل مع التوحد هي ان احنا
ندخل على العالم الطفل عنده التوحد يعني
مثلا اذا كان هو يحب يلعب مثلا في الماء
ندخل نلعب معاه ونبتدي نستكشف عالمه
ونبتدي نعلمه بهذه الطريقه يعني ما نقعد
نقول له انت تعال على المكتب عندي على
الدرج وادرس وانا بعلمك لا احنا بندخل على
الشيء اللي يحب يسويه بندخل وبنتوسع من
هذا النطاق يعني هو يحب مثلا يلعب في
الماي نروح نحط الكور نعدل يتعلم الارقام
نتعلم الالوان يتعلم الاحجام يعني انت
تدخلين في عالمه وتبتدين تعلمينه بالطريقه
اللي هو يحبها
في بعض الاطفال يصير عندهم اصوات معينه
ضايقه اذونهم في ليتات معينه فانتبه اذا
وديتيه حق اماكن مزعجه يمكن تلاقينا هي
تتضايق او او يصرخ فتشوفي هو شنو البيئه
اللي يحبها عشان نقدر نطلع ونقضي وقت حلو
معه